willkommen sind kinder zur endstation
nothilfe für die schweiz hat vollkommen
tage vor kreuth sehr große diskussion
also heftige diskussionen und hierdurch
in den kinos
die ge hat geschrieben wer entscheidet
eigentlich ob jemand bleiben darf oder
nicht und wie kann man das eigentlich
entscheiden gute reportage weiter
ich habe in den letzten zwei tagen
mächtig sind somit zum beantworten
ich glaube sehr schön ich so wer
entscheidet was tisches asylverfahren
wie ich es nationalstaatliches bundes
verfahren das heißt für asyl bandbreite
der schweiz denn das staatssekretariat
für migration beantworte sie mischen und
wenn der entscheid eine post der
kommende einmal aufwachte und zwar vom
bundesverwaltungsgericht auf achten dass
ich in st gallen
und wenn das stand der definitiv
entscheiden ganz wenige ausnahmen auch
wiedergabe das ist sehr sagte ja ich
habe für äußeres schwer wichtig dass der
süden scheint gleich mit zwei frau das
erste wo beantwortet wird im asyl
entscheidung pro asyl bemüht
und wenn die mit ja beantwortet wird
einen quicktipp lemgo suisse und roche
bleibe
und wenn hier mit nein beantwortet wird
dann wird es auch abgelehnt aber da muss
man wie immer noch pro person überhaupt
bewies also ausgeschafft werden
das nahm er dann wegweisung des vollzugs
hindernisse wie gut kommen die person
ums schaf oder wie gibt es irgendwie
geht kriegt faktischen flug auf gibt es
möglichkeiten ist wieso sollten sie ihre
sache
und wenn das wäre mit person nicht raus
schaffen dann kriegt man es dass die
vorläufig aufgenommen
und wenn mir das einfach mit ja
beantwortet dass man die personen raum
schafft einen gibt es dann gehts
negativen asylentscheid und weg wie sie
die person justiz verlangt
kontakt kann holly hunter vision negativ
entscheidend sind weg wissen aus der
scharfe wind konnten konnten wichtige
die kontrolle migrationsbehörde zweimal
mit controls polizei hieß und du musst
in der nacht konnten verteilt ja oh du
schöner der zweite teil so wie er sich
entscheidet und ich glaube das wird sehr
kompliziert die frau das asyl- und
schätzen zu kompliziert war wie eine
komplette wenn einem das mir
interessiert findet man auf der webseite
vom staatssekretariat für migration oder
flüchtlingshilfe finden sehr viele
informationen dazu was geklärt ist und
sich von ich mir sagen dass die
merksteiner ich jetzt kontakt chemie
film der ihn ihres asylgesuch abgelehnt
wurde es morgen und der glaubwürdigkeit
also dass staatssekretär für migration
in wird glaubt hat die dass die
geschichte wo sie erzählt und boris oder
sie haben zu wenig babys bringen für die
jazz mit tomczyk ich sehe hier den job
des reporters nur zur hälfte gemacht man
hätte die behörden viel mehr ins licht
setzen müssen dass sich der reporter mit
einer e mail als antwort zufrieden gibt
ist erstaunlich man sollte meinen der
sfv genug an die entsprechenden
verantwortlichen zu kommen
so bleibt nur der eindruck naja ist ja
nur schade darum danke für den kommentar
das werde ich nicht so dass das nur das
paar mails sind ich meine film wirklich
unzählige e-mails und telefonate geführt
dass hunderte ich nicht alles in vielen
menschen schwer in gang gekommen würden
wir nach zwei augen wenn ich mit
unglaublich vielen telefonieren
das ist ja sowieso einen film macht es
mir als mega viel muss abklären und
moscow fact checking machen wo dazu
gehört und ich schlafe gemacht haben
das thema allgemein morgen wie sehr viel
zwischen schiri gibt oder ich bleibe
allgemein ist ja schon so dass die
kontakte haben damit sehr prekär das
heißt ich bevor ich sie treffe also für
den film drauf haben und sie sich einmal
so getroffen um ihn erklären was sie
erwartet was ich mache
und was ich mache also was ich möchte
sprechen und auch das nachbarhaus
verstanden ist dass man viel im genre
oder bitte behörden in zürich bin ich
dem nachgegangen
allgemein will sie stoff befehlsstelle
für ihre rechtswidrigen rechtswidrigen
aufenthalt sondern wie sie die
strafbefehl spezifisches stelle wenn sie
glück kontrolliert am ort wo sie wohnen
also in der not hilft nur eine
spezifische ort wohnen das ist pflicht
also die person muss steht offenbar sie
und im kanton zürich und ein polizeiauto
räume wo du musst sie und gibt der us
value illegal da aber wie du
rechtswidrig in der schweiz bis und das
machen nicht viele kommen konnten das
machen nur ganz vereinzelt kann tönt es
gibt schon auch andere konnten wo bussen
ausstellen es waagerecht wenigen tagen
aber das meistens auch wenn du zur
gewichtskontrolle wunsch und dann
feststellt wird also dann durchaus kann
muss ich zeigen so systematisch wem
kommt und sie wird es müssen nicht
gemacht und da stand ich wähle wisse um
features bin ich dann der behörde
nachkommen herausfinde wer wieso gehst
entscheid dass wir genau das macht und
ich starte ich sowohl natürliche spitze
unbefriedigend auch chemie ich das nicht
sagte joder system und dem grund aber
natürlich als bc symptomatisch das hat
die einzelnen behörde sein die amis
machen halt nur genau ihre spezifische
teil der rest machte brothers und so zum
schluss ja nimmer geht recht
verantwortlich übernimmt der cd the
mechanic kostenlose krankenkasse tk
werden übernommen die acht sturz sind
zusätzlich taschengeld womit man sich
täglich zum beispiel ein patient wie
gesagt liter bier kaufen kann deshalb
verschiedenen kommentare und abschieden
diskussion in der kommentarspalte was
jetzt genau die nothilfe beinhaltet und
das für mich völlig verständlich will
dass ich sehr unübersichtliche system
will so kontrolle kritischer recherchen
der film an ich hatte mich einfach alle
container aus liebe zur musik finden was
beinhaltet die nothilfe zeit genau
erkannt
da gibt es wirklich große unterschied
und eines oskar dass wenn geld auszahlt
wird dann ist das auch ganz und er muss
mit adidas werde ihren idealen container
konnten graubünden das ist ja da kommt
und thurgau und teilweise konnten dort
und im tessin wo es kalt nach tasci wird
ja alle anderen konnten wird irgend ein
betrag von ca im schnitt 8 franken davon
ab wie es der content sie und ich wissen
wie viel denken gibt die schweiz kann
sich schämen dafür wie sie den
asylsuchenden umgehend absolut
menschlich unwürdig die meisten dieser
menschen wollen arbeiten wollen einen
teil der gesellschaft sein
ja das ist viel kommentar an dem
mega-betrug foxi und sich freute dass
sie das existiert in der schweiz und wie
man ihnen helfen und unterstützen
und ich glaube es wird also oder diät
nothilfe des politisches thema
es wird natürlich sehr oft kritisiert es
gibt immer wieder politische bewegung
und angeles wo er besagt dass das system
not hilft das ist manche würdig oder das
ermöglicht nur dass manche würdigste sie
dort aktuell gibt es zum beispiel im
nationalrat emotion vor der fab four die
nothilfe einmalig schon längere den otev
sind einmalig und bestimmte umstand ein
aufenthaltsstatus gibt wie das wenn man
langfristig werden notenblatt does not
mancher würdigen
ich bin wild shinjuku schikane
überlebens und mancher und der
gesellschaft sie das bedürfnis dass ich
von der gesellschaft nicht mehr gespielt
das bedürfnis oder das merken wo die
probleme wo man die spezifische probleme
wo man dem herkunftsort hier gibt es
nicht mehr und man hat jetzt ein problem
da aber die so genau dass grund
sicherheitsgefühl oder dass das deutsch
und dass die dankbarkeit forschungsmarkt
möchte mit dem labor machen und ein
feiner gesellschaft sie und hat mit
scharfer und ich habe das schwierigste
ist so dass man nicht niedermachen
das macht verdammt dazu ist einfach vor
sich
schlager und möglichen wie kreatives
machen
ich weiß dass es rund um die nothilfe
zentrum verschiedenste die
zivilgesellschaftliche initiative geht
oft auch kirchliche initiative vovo
sachen mache etwas zum diskurs gibt oder
was gut für zu fertigen wir ganz direkt
queen ist auch das machen und ich bin
sicher wenn es lokale oder wenn es not
hilfe zentrum mit dem grafik kugelt dass
man das findet der markt es gibt kein
fan von diesem moderator man sollte
neutral berichten die leute können sich
dann selber eine meinung bilden für mich
unprofessionell dass themen andererseits
ist interessant danke das ist mehr ihm
ein frohes und fragt wo von geräten und
wieso nicht mehr spezifischen jeter nur
und mit manchen in der not hilft räte
und ich habe jetzt sicherlich stellen
offene fragen und die frage schon
spezifisch formuliert dass ich möchte
wissen was macht es mit der mancher wenn
man lang in der nothilfe
ich habe dem ibm es treffe überall sieht
man sehr oft über asylsuchende oft über
will das ganze system und die bezahlung
fakt aber mehrere zelte mit der manager
termine und ich glaube dass ich mich
fragte oder wer ist das und was macht
das mit einem über jahre vor deren not
hilft und dann fragt nicht mehr gegangen
für die frage jetzt kasse gemacht mit
üblem anders als mit menschen in not
hilft sie haben sie auch transparent sie
über was mich bewegt und wieso der ich
bin manchmal gibt es auch erzählt mal
lotto und effizient wird über hunger
meine dass das fahrzeug mitunter tut zog
und es wäre wahrscheinlich dann wird
nicht zeigen dass mich das bewegt und
irgendwie so spielt die coolness zu ich
glaube das glaube ich nicht was ich habe
versucht das wären immerhin bis bewegt
oder aber einig ein abschlussfoto click
cpc schätze dass das basiert auf der
basis verteilen wir nicht getan und alle
mythen und mit mir den film uhr geht die
hand die gleiche ausgangslage nach dem
schluss zu so ein konkurrierendes
die nothilfe ich finde das kann ich sie
oder sage ich am schluss der sich
zusammenfinden so das lied so markiert
werden und ich glaube dass
schlussfolgerung ich ziehe aus dem man
nicht erlebt haben das hat alle anderen
die gleich voraussetzungen oder mann und
ich könnte ihre eigene schlussfolgerung
ziehen dass li gibt es wird mehr mittel
um schlussendlich ist es durch ihre
entscheidung das bliebe oder ergebnis
verpasst man sie möchte gar getötet sie
durch rückkehrhilfen das nerve zwei
fragen aber ich finde das gut die frage
habe ich sowieso wie da sind oder
natürlich gesprochen mit anna lüth und
die schweizer sowieso sie eine
einzelfall sind aber ich finde
filmisches kabinett wichtig wie für die
film ist doch wichtig was macht mit
ihnen dass sie noch da sind und ich
glaube was ich werkmärkte haben in der
recherche wie der film so der grund
wieso personen oder ist immer sehr
individuell und das erkläre das muss man
mitunter uns holen zu können erklärt
wieso jetzt genau die person noch da ist
ein trupp verrückte hilft ja manchmal
negativen asylentscheid hand und schwyz
verleitet die rückkehrhilfe beitragen
dass unterschiedliche betrag je nachdem
wie man das projekt mache die im
herkunftsland website familie gerne zu
uns kommen sagt je länger die schweiz
spielt desto weniger rückkehrhilfe
geht's juli schreibt herr bolz manchmal
als social project mit lappen eine
zweifach franken
momentan plant dann haben sie bereit so
wie er am neustädter sonne und es schon
überlegt sie ob ich irgendwas l 811
nothilfe zentrum iz zwei wochen einig
sieht wie sich das auf während es ein
sehr bewusst geld aus dem chat und zwar
mit frack ist erstens wir legt sich mit
einer note von der us-kommission oder
und zweitens glaube ich nicht nothilfe
sind nicht nur die acht franken note in
fischen nicht nur das leben in einer
kollektiv unterkunft sondern nothilfe
ist ja und dass das labor und angst vor
polizei
unter absoluter priorität aber das ist
eine lampe ohne zukunft ohne die
möglichkeit des lappens blauen also das
gefühl die erfahrung kann ich nicht nach
oben
ich habe einen schweizer pass ich bin
ladens plan
ich kann nicht verstehen das ist für
mich nicht vorstellbar ist aber schluss
ich weiß nicht wie sich das auf und
darum haben wir uns spezifische
entschieden das netz machen
ich bin anderer kontext 115 machen und
den fokus ihres ich versuche mancher
kann es lernen und mit ihnen verbringe
und und des vertrauens grüne mit manchen
wohl halb so lang wie die minarett dass
sie mir das könnte erzählt ford wie das
ist der käfer haben schiebt sie
interessante doku vielen dank einige
menschen können jetzt erfahren schlimm
das ist herzkrank und die rallye haut an
wurzel like-button abonnieren der kanal
und nachsichtig siena steht prof